it's nearly 50 years since turkey took
control of the north of cyprus
and the island remains split to this day
and divisions
continue between the greek and turkish
cypriot communities
well those divisions provide the
backdrop to a new novel by the british
turkish novelist elif shafak called the
island
of missing trees and she joins me now
i'm very glad to say very good to talk
to you and got to explain
the title uh are all the trees really
missing in cyprus
um well in some ways they are of course
cyprus is such a beautiful island
with beautiful people but at the same
time it's it's an island of
unhealed wombs stories but also
silences uh and i think i wanted to talk
about
roots how does it feel to be uprooted um
and and lament also the loss of trees
and this
ecological crisis that is very much part
of the human history and story
and at the center of the novel is is a
love story and with you mention roots
with
almost traditional roots there are
elements of romeo and juliet about it
love across the divide
indeed in in in a way there is because
there's kostas with greek
christian the greek cypriot and there's
definite who is
turkish cypriots muslim so they do come
from different backgrounds and there's
ada
their child who has been named after the
island of cyprus but she has never been
there
i think i wanted to tackle
intergenerational memory
trauma how the stories and silences in
our families shape us
but as at the same time i wanted to see
if hope is possible
coexistence and peace is possible and in
order to arrive there i think we need to
take a broader
look at the story and speaking in the
voice of the trees
i hope gave me that that angle that i
needed
and it has such relevance of course to
modern day cyprus but
uh beyond there are there are so many
communities even within europe that
face such divisions
i sincerely hope and believe that you
know many people coming from
very different backgrounds but similarly
troubled histories complex histories
can relate to this book i have met lots
of immigrant families families in exile
where the first generation of course
they have under
you know they went through the the
biggest difficulties and they carry the
memories
of those obstacles um but perhaps they
don't know how to talk about it and then
the second generation is busy
belonging finding their feet and they
don't want to talk about the past as
much
but then there's the third fourth
generation the youngest
in these families who are keen to learn
more about their identity the stories
and the trajectories of their ancestors
so it's very interesting to to meet
young people
with older memories or curiosity for the
past
and as you pointed out there are many
divided lands there are many lands of
partition
and families coming from such
backgrounds all around the world
and elephant you're with us i can't not
ask you about these
terrible scenes we're seeing from turkey
at the moment these
wildfires that are affecting so many
parts of the country i mean your
thoughts about those and
maybe some thoughts as well about the
government seeming
unpreparedness for it all no fire
fighting aircraft turning down uh help
from
other nations what do you make of it all
yes it's absolutely it's just
heartbreaking you know and
also it's so frustrating this sense of
helplessness
that many people right now are feeling
in turkey
because these wildfires are destroying
homes
lives entire ecosystems and the
government
has been completely incompetent if you
voice this
immediately you are regarded as a
traitor or you know accused of betrayal
um i think this is a important moment
also for
international cooperation and support
and and help but it's also a moment of
awakening
not only in turkey across the world to
understand
how climate change is real it is
happening
day by day in front of our eyes so there
is the governmental incompetence on the
one side
and this bigger picture of our climate
crisis on the other hand
i don't know if you've seen this video
that was released today
with the screams of animals who are
dying in the in the wildfires
entire natural habitats are being
destroyed in turkey
it's utterly heartbreaking it really is
do you have any
family or friends who are being affected
by it
of course i have um family and friends
especially
marmary's boardroom you know every day i
correspond i talk to them
people are terrified and and they're not
getting enough
help they are trying to save their homes
at the same time the trees
there's a there's utter chaos at the
moment
i don't know if you want to get into it
but do you think that uh richard
berdowan's
government his regime actually takes
climate change
seriously enough
i i do not think they take climate
change seriously enough also
i don't think they take the civil
society seriously
you know um turkey as you know has
become
more authoritarian over the years it has
become more nationalists more
of religious fundamentalism that is not
the way forward what we need is a proper
you know pluralistic democracy in which
diversity there is diversity and
equality so
unfortunately whether it's climate or or
the civil society or democracy or or
rule of law or freedom of speech
there's a lot that we need to talk about
when we talk about turkey
it has been fantastic talking to you
thank you so much for covering
so much ground in our short time
available best of luck
with the novel the island of missing
trees elif shafak there
thank you for having me